I've been in games 23 years now and it's
like I literally remember times when
executives from publishers would tell us
things like first person games don't
sell or the RPG is dead or stealth games
nobody wants that I think some some
studios maybe are immediately successful
with one game and they go big you know
they have like a lot of funding so they
arrive and they they hire like a big
team and so that's not our case we
started four people were very broke for
a long time our first game was kind of
known in the in the fans community for
this kind of game but it was not
successful financially so it was it was
a long struggle you know I got in as
many do into the game industry about the
age of 19 I published you know my first
game and been making a few on my own I
had that but pretty much through my
whole career I've been the oldest guy in
the industry we were all you know kind
of young punks how to change the world
and and you know we had these ideas that
we just needed to explore it was it
wasn't like we wanted to or we kind of
thought ya might be cool it was a need
you know we had no choice
[Music]